la mafia est en france depuis longtemps et
bien que les français utilisent ce mot
il y a du crime organisé
Français très articulé très puissant
et avec de belles alliances car c'est un
structuration internationale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la plupart de la cocaïne dans le monde
il est produit dans trois pays colombie pérou
Bolivie
et est devenu un monopole du cartel
les mexicains exactement aussi bien que moi
produits sont devenus le monopole de
films amazon et netflix
la coca arrive en france par la route
atlantic expédie presque toujours des navires qui
ils transportent la cocaïne de deux manières
Le fret tchèque s'appelle le fret tchèque
signifie qui dirige le navire
il ne sait rien et la coke est cachée dans le
produits qu'il ne transporte pas
ils ne sont rien et l'autre est la déclinaison
au lieu de cela la charge évidente qui est qui est
portant le naviguer qui conduit je
les gestionnaires savent exactement que
porter une couverture
une fois que vous arrivez en afrique, vous le mettez là
ils stockent dans des entrepôts et il est amené
par camion du désert le maghreb
il y a souvent de petits petits bateaux
ce sont des voiliers qui partent et ramènent
puis il y a de la cocaïne sur les plages
une autre possibilité
pourtant beaucoup de coke utilisé arrive dans le
Les ports français néerlandais en fait un
des ports favoris de l'arc
trafiquants pour ensuite revendre en france et
rotterdam tu arrives et le coke est à l'intérieur
conteneur parce que les ports sont choisis
important comme par exemple rotterdam
car plus le port et rapide rapide plus
difficile de trouver de la cocaïne si vous faites la police
vous décidez de passer tous les douanes
conteneur en le vérifiant avec des chiens avec
les scanners que vous fabriquez sont très lents
le dédouanement
puis les entreprises
le transitaire ne veut plus travailler
avec lequel vous portez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la distribution de coke de haschich
de la marijuana de l'ecstasy du crack est
le tout aux dépens des organisations
Les criminels locaux français où finissent-ils
tout cet argent dans les banques françaises
où va l'argent dans les banques
Les Luxembourgeois et que faire d'eux tous
cette masse d'argent qui bouge
construire des palais acheter des maisons oui
recycle dans les entreprises qui le font
distribution de collecte de déchets
grands supermarchés petroni
distribution alimentaire
dans les caisses de l'économie légale
l'économie légale est de l'argent liquide qui
ils arrivent constamment tous les jours
dans l'économie légale du tissu
Français
[Musique]